parler justement de ces inquiétudes
françois boulot avocat est avec nous en
direct bonsoir m merci d'être avec nous
on a entendu donc ses inquiétudes sur
l'après 11 mai sur 7 après confinement
est ce que selon vous ce sont des
inquiétudes justifiées
oui bonsoir évidemment elles sont
justifiées ses inquiétudes parce que
s'ils ont des zooms un peu sur la
période sur quelques années on se rend
compte que cette crise sanitaire elle
est intervenue dans un contexte social
qui était déjà extrêmement explosif
on avait eu évidemment le mouvement des
gilets jaunes qui depuis le 17 avant
2018 auxquels s'étaient ajoutés
le mouvement de grève l historique
contre la réforme des retraites ont tous
se souvient que le gouvernement il finit
avait dû utiliser le 49-3 qui avait mis
en colère
énormément de gens et finalement le si
cette réforme est suspendu c'est à la
faveur de cette crise sanitaire donc on
a une crise sanitaire qui est venue
s'ajouter à une crise sociale et
économique existante
pendant la crise sanitaire tout le monde
a vu que finalement c'était la
confirmation de la dénonciation des
politiques néolibérales qui était
conduite depuis des années puisque si
nous sommes retrouvé démuni pour faire
face à la crise
et bien c'est parce que nous n'avions
pas de masque pas de test pas de moyens
de protection et les soignants en ont
été évidemment les premières victimes
qui est manifestée depuis plus d'un an
dans la rue donc finalement tous à
attiser la colère en plus de cela on a
ajouté les mensonge inouï du
gouvernement qui n'a cessé de mentir je
vais pas reprendre tous les exemples
mais notamment sur les masques puisqu'il
n'y avait pas de masque gouvernement
nous expliquer que des thés inutile
d'emporter finalement on voit bien que
tout cela fait que toutes les crises
successives qui sont ensemble de naître
dans le pays depuis quelques années ne
sont jamais résolus et enfin on sait
désormais que évidemment le confinement
a mis en difficulté de manière très
grave et très profonde
un certain nombre d'entreprises
d'artisans de commerçants mais également
par voie de conséquence de salariés donc
il ya une catastrophe économique qui
s'annonce il va y avoir des choix
extrêmement important sur le plan
politique a repéré et ce qui est à
redouter c'est finalement le pouvoir
reste inflexible
comme il l'a toujours été et j'ai lu
très récemment
intervention d'emmanuel todd interview
d'emmanuel todd qui explique si vous
voulez que quand les gens vous ne leur
permettait pas de juger les responsables
et on voit qu'aujourd'hui il ya une loi
d'amnistié qui veut être prises par le
pouvoir pour s'exonérer de toute
responsabilité pénale
si d'un côté vous empêchez les
responsables d'être jugés et que de
l'autre finalement les gens ne croient
plus en l'élection parce que quoi qu'il
arrive ce sont toujours les mêmes c'est
à dire des libéraux qui arrivent au
pouvoir
et bien finalement vous empêcher toute
possibilité d'un changement pacifique et
vous rêvez vous rendez donc inévitable
un changement qui s'effectuera dans des
conditions violentes
voilà le soir nous tout de même l'état a
été assez généreux pour beaucoup
d'observateurs rappellent que la moitié
des salariés dans le privé ont été mis
au chômage partiel avec des aides
notamment pour les plus modestes
également la réforme des retraites vous
l'avais dit à la faveur si j'ose dire de
cette crise qui a été donc abandonné
est-ce que tout de même ce n'est pas de
nature à infléchir un petit peu les
colères la colère des français
aujourd'hui selon vous je crois que les
mesures qui ont été prises étaient les
mesures minimales mais on l'a vu dans
votre reportage
il ya quelques instants il ya beaucoup
de personnes pour qui ces mesures sont
insuffisantes
c'est ce qu'il faut bien comprendre
c'est que pour l'instant nous ne sommes
qu'au début de cette crise économique
la déflagration qui va venir sera bien
plus importante ce qui fait qu'on va
avoir des choix extrêmement important
affaire emmanuelle maintenant on va
devoir faire des choix
en gros la question va se poser de
savoir et se consomme le sisp on sauve
le système d'avant où est-ce qu'on
change de système
la première des conséquences c'est de
répondre à la question qui va payer les
conséquences de cette crise économique
est ce que ce sont toujours les mêmes
est ce que c'est la classe moyenne qui
va payer ou est ce que enfin ce sont les
ultra riches de ce pays qui vont payer
aujourd'hui il ya vincent lindon d'un
comédien qui a enregistré un appel et
qui a par exemple fait une proposition
extrêmement concrètes en indiquant qu'
on pourrait envisager que les gros
patrimoines c'était des patrimoines
supérieurs à 10 millions d'euros
et bien pour ça pour les sommes de
patrimoine qui dépasse 10 millions
d'euros il y aurait une taxe entrera et
5% ont déterminé mais sur le principe
voyez que ce serait la seule manière
effectivement d'éponger les conséquences
de cette crise sans faire porter le
poids des conséquences sociales
économiques désastreuses qui vont
déferler sur les gens qui sont toujours
les plus touchées les plus précaires ou
ceux qui payent toujours les impôts dans
ce prix est évidemment il faudrait que
cette taxe soit accompagnée de mesures
extrêmement dissuasif en terme de
sanction parce qu'on sait qu'on ne
pourra pas compter sur la solidarité
spontanée je dirais de tous les ultra
riches non merci beaucoup françois
boulot d'avoir été avec nous en direct
sur rt france